I'm gonna get to this in a second but
can I tell you how happy I am for you
and excited for you but are you prepared
because you're not gonna sleep again for
another 1820 years all right so many of
these ladies here and you see a sea of
black and you see the men wearing
buttons and you see the men wearing but
what does that mean to you today we were
black for so many reasons we wear black
to say times up on the imbalance of
power and abuse of power we wear black
for all the women and whistleblowers who
came forward
Asya agente rosanna arquette Ashley Judd
Olivia Munn Gabrielle Union Terry Crews
and we're standing here because of the
courage they had and also women in all
industries and men in all industries are
standing up and saying enough with
discrimination and harassment and abuse
we deserve equality and this time is up
have you ladies just been on the phone
for like the last three weeks calling
everyone yes it's been like four four we
have four full-time jobs and three of
them more times up
we are linked in arms with all the women
here and we're linked in arms with uh
with all industries so that tonight
where this fund is going to help
restaurant workers domestic workers
hotel workers foreign workers so it took
a village no absolutely and we hope that
people know
that is one award show can't show you
everything but this can be a start and
hopefully this will spread to all
interest rates at start how much start
16 million already we put our our our
funds times a Legal Defense Fund that's
gonna provide legal resources to people
who need them for on-the-job harassment
suits and it's not people just in
Hollywood and it's not just women it's
men as well and and they have endured a
lot of these same issues that we're
talking about right now so I think it's
just about leveling the playing field
absolutely and this isn't about men or
women it's about power and the abuse of
power
[Music]